hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages
as they arrive and it's time to see
what's making the headlines with the
columnist broadcaster steve richards
and the economist senior editor anne
mckelvoy and they're going to be
with us right through to midnight for
our extended news review
so a welcome to both of you hope you're
feeling energetic
this long night ahead we'll be talking
to you in just a moment
first let's take a look then at what's
making the front pages and the metro
first of all leads with the news that
no covert deaths were recorded today
that's the first time
since march of last year the daily mail
suggests that
that news means that people have nothing
to fear
from freedom the daily telegraph reports
that boris johnson is being
pressured to delay the planned reopening
on june the 21st
following the scottish first minister
nicholas sturgeon's decision
to slow the unlocking process north of
the border
while the times argues the figures mean
there is fresh
hope for the lifting of restrictions on
june the 21st
the guardian meanwhile leads with
criticisms over the government's 1.4
billion pound plan
to help students catch up on lost
education
as a result of the pandemic
so those are all the papers we've got so
far we'll of course show the other front
pages as they come in but
uh let's turn now to steve richardson
and mckelvoy a proper hello to both of
you
to go through some of those front pages
first of all
and steve we're going to kick off with
the metro aren't we which sums up what
many of the papers so far
are leading on and this is the fact that
today there wasn't as they put it a
single covert death recorded
in the uk certainly in the last 24 hours
i mean that makes a lot of the headlines
doesn't it
it does and it's a very striking
statistic
you know that no one has died in this
period
and we're not used to these statistics
which are
optimistic hopeful etc
but i kind of i hope i'm wrong
but it all feels slightly too neat to me
that as this so-called indian variant
spreads there is this kind of
unqualified
optimism i still think there needs to be
some
caution but you can see the pressure on
boris johnson
to be not cautious in the headlines
tomorrow and fair enough you know we've
had miserable evenings reviewing front
pages
that's a good statistic but underneath
that statistic there is still
quite a few concerns and is interesting
as you said in your
intro that nicola sturgeon is already
exerting caution
in the immediate future in the light of
this variant
so yeah great this is a good this
statistic to celebrate but i kind of
think there are
underlying things that we need to watch
as well
and what do you make of it i mean
nicholas thirteen is pictured there on
the front of the metro
isn't she because she's announced today
that there'll be a slowing of the easing
of restrictions in scotland
i mean how much has that put pressure on
boris johnson as he makes his decision
he has to make his decision i think by
the 14th
of june about whether or not all those
restrictions are
lifted as planned on the 21st i mean
there are lots of different conflicting
pressures on him
there are and to be fair on the
government's position
it would seem that there is enough
evidence certainly
from the new uh cases that are coming
through now at quite
some speed of the indian variants of
course the
papers were going largely with that good
news
of no cover death in a day which is
fantastic news
but that is still a long way from saying
that you're out of the woods because you
have a lot of
much younger people being infected with
the indian variant
than were classically being infected
before that's also partly good news
because uh
those of us who should we say that no
longer 21 although we may or may not
look at on camera
have probably had our second jabs and
the more people have their second jabs
um you know obviously the better the
protection but i i
wouldn't completely underplay the
pressure on the prime minister isn't
just a sort of gung-ho
right to center newspapers and back
benches businesses are
desperate for a reopening or at least
should we say to get
as few restrictions in place as possible
uk hospitality
is in a dreadful state and with that
goes livelihoods goes jobs
and it gets harder and harder to recover
the more of these lockdowns we've had
which have been
successive so there is real pressure on
the prime minister i know that
in the last week we heard an
extraordinary account from dominic
cummings saying the prime minister
was being too lackadaisical if you like
in putting
lives at risk but we mustn't forget that
there is a very high cost to be counted
too
if this keeps being delayed so i think
this is an invidious position he's in
and yet as you write about scotland
nicholas sturgeon that has has gone with
a more cautious line let's see if the
prime minister
is forced to follow well yes and and if
we pick up the guardians coverage of
this um steve they don't make it their
main story
but the second story first day without
virus death in 10 months
but they say in their copy here
government sources have suggested that
boris johnson was still
minded to to lift those final social
social distancing
restrictions on june the 24th i mean do
you think it's right that he will be
very aware not just the back benches i
think we'll come on to that that in a
moment
but also those businesses who are
desperate
to get up and running again and some of
them can only do that properly
um if restrictions are lifted
and also those people who will say so
many people have been vaccinated
what's the point of people being
vaccinated if you can't lift
restrictions
steve you look like you're frozen i
don't know if you can still hear me
no i think we have lost uh steve's line
there we'll try and reconnect with that
but and perhaps you could
pick up on that for me i mean obviously
there are those those different
pressures businesses but also people
saying what was vaccination
for yes that is true and i think that
the problem that the government if you
like sort of set
itself although i have some sympathy
with the position that there are
trade-offs whenever you choose to do it
or not do it there are trade-offs that
really matter to people's
lives and opportunities and well-being
but there is i think a problem and boris
johnson has fallen into this before is
creating expectation around a date
so it's the date not data argument and
as the data moves if it does
continue to move against uh reopening a
full reopening on the 21st
then he will stand accused and last week
was i think the
first bite at the cherry that we saw
from dominic cummings but there will be
more criticism
from those who said you are not really
doing what you said you would do which
was
make the policy according to the data
you have available you've got yourself
stuck with a date and you don't want to
back off it certainly there will be
people saying well i've had all my
vaccinations i've had
one i've had two you know i'm a bit
covered or i'm actually
almost as near dammit fully covered now
you you tell me i have to
to to stay at home again or you go down
the vaccine passport route but the
government's made pretty clear i think
having
road tested that that voters don't
really like the idea
of a kind of two or multi-tier society
in which i can go out but my
younger relatives can't and i think that
would would land very badly so
you know he may have backed himself into
quite a corner with this date for the
21st of june or he may
be lucky and the variant subsides we
don't know yet
well yes and and i'm pleased to tell you
that we are rejoined by steve there he
is
animated once again good to see you back
i don't know what happened no these
things happen we're all so used to it
now aren't we
in the age of zoom interviews and
conversations so don't worry at all
we're going to move on to the daily
telegraph steve because
inc included in their lead article is
that reflecting the fact that a number
of backbenchers are also putting
pressure on on boris johnson how much is
he likely to listen to them
well according to dominic cummings and
others
a great deal but this is the problem
and and sorry i don't know if you heard
me say before i was
rudely cut off and brilliantly
highlighted the dilemmas of leadership
in this it is it is a real invidious
position
but yeah sure tory mp say come on june
the 21st let's open everything up
and others will as well a lot of the
newspapers and there is an economic case
for doing so
but if the data suggests
that this is risky it will prove
counterproductive
we've been through this so many times
i hope his libertarian instincts
johnson's
is countered by a very careful review of
the data
if the data says go for it great if not
i hope he's cautious but cummings in
that compelling
seven hour testimony which i watched i'm
sure and watched
suggest that might not be the case and
that's and that's dangerous
for the country and steve um
now that we've got you back i'm going to
make most of you do you think it's
possible that
the decision could be a bit of a fudge
if you like you could say
well we're going to loosen these
restrictions but there are a few things
that we're going to hold back for the
time being so people get a bit of a
mixed bag they get a sense that
they're getting a bit more freedom if
not the whole thing
well it might be described as a fudge
but maybe that's quite sensible
i i don't know i think they will wait
and see what the
data is nearer the time and it's going
to be a very very
tough call but that wouldn't be a fudge
necessarily
maybe that would be quite sensible to
say more can open up but not everything
and i you know sorry to be hesitant
and pessimistic but i i've done
quite a lot of these newspaper reviews
with you where we've talked about
oh yeah christmas we've got to go ahead
the awesome yeah
gotta open up and all sorts of
nightmares have followed from that now
hopefully with the vaccines
that's not the case this time but i do
think they've got to do
a very careful review of that data
in a 10 days time or whatever the final
deadline is
and a fudge might be the most sensible
response
and it's interesting to see how the
papers do play it the daily mail is
making clear very much
their opinion on this on their front
page aren't they they're saying zero
deaths
nothing to fear from freedom they're
making it very clear where they stand
do we get any sense do you think of what
the public thinks
well i think that the trouble is it
rather depends how you put the the
question so that
the male is is has always i think really
been on this
side of the the balance sheet and only
just about
pull back before christmas it was
understood and said to understood why
christmas had to be much more
constrained
there is i think a desire among a lot of
people to get back to mingle et cetera
because i don't totally understand
a lot of readers are actually small c
conservative readers
are often small c conservative about
health risks as well
so i think sometimes it's not exactly
the papers there's a
view that they really have an insight
into the souls of their readers and they
understand everything from
from their market research but quite
often this can just be
views that an editor has or they might
feel that they want to be
in strong in the argument even if
there's there's
evidence on both sides so i'm not
absolutely
convinced as to why the mail should be
so strongly in favor of
freedom day as it appears to be quite a
lot of readers
i think are happy to accept the
constraints but you know i think what
this gets the heart of is
what do you think is a sensible
interpretation of the data seems
absolutely right
i'm also work for the economist you know
we data for breakfast lunch and dinner
but we do have arguments about what data
means and we do have debates
about if you were going to open some
things not others where would you stop
and some of the things that people maybe
would think or not so dangerous might
turn out to be so for certain groups of
the population
so then you get into kind of local
lockdown so people really didn't like
those did they
so i think it's to say to be sensible
about the data unless
one's always going to go for the most
stringent approach possible which case
you should level with the public and say
so
well you know that's not really the way
that boris johnson
has conducted himself and politically
you have to say
so far you know he's hung on to his
heart he's got problems
there's nobody else touching him in the
opinion polls well it's going to be a
really interesting couple of weeks isn't
it as that
boris johnson gears up to making that
decision but we're going to take a pause
right now
lots more to talk about in just a moment
including does the government's plan to
help
students catch up after the pandemic
make the grade we're going to be talking
about that in just a moment
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me tonight steve richards
and ann
mcelvoy well welcome back to both of you
and the guardian we're kicking off with
this time anne aren't we
a covid tuition catch-up plan dismissed
as inadequate
so who is saying it's inadequate
well this is really the the plan to
spend money which actually looks like a
reasonably good headline figure of money
on
catching up children who fall in behind
or in danger of falling behind
because of the gaps in their schooling
in this rather erratic exam system
the trouble is that it's really a quite
small amount of money when you
kind of disaggregate it across the the
number of of groups with
school further education et cetera who
would have a claim on it
i always feel it's a bit like this any
uh thing to do with education spending
is
always a bit cheese paired and this is
no exception
i do think although the guardian um sort
of slightly true to form here the
guardian
goes on the fact that there's never
enough money you know there's just never
enough money for everything that god you
would like it for
but in fairness what they are pointing
out that we're lagging on having
anything that we could really
put into place so in terms of what the
quality and reliability and consistency
of digital education and how you carry
that through these very long summers i
mean i have a
daughter at home post sort of gcses
whatever they are this year
for 12 weeks but you know there are
certainly a lot of children who are
suffering much more where they're in
homes where they can't continue to learn
easily without support
and that that is going to knock on in
terms of a big social mobility problem
which i think will be laid at the
government store so i think this isn't
only
the classic complaint about there's
never enough uh money for anything to do
with schools though it is that
it's something that is going to have
more serious consequences and
hence the front page billing steve do
you think that's right
yeah i think it's a massive challenge
for the government
to address the astonishing
shortfall in education unavoidable over
the last
year or 18 months and it will need
big thinking and some of it will be
money i'm afraid um there's no getting
away from it
and they need to think big about this
now i you know the headline
dismissed as inadequate inadequate some
vague
word and term but i do think it's going
to involve some
really big thinking to address this
shortfall in the coming
months and dan i'm just going to move
this on very swiftly to a little article
on the front of the daily telegraph
um about uh weather spoons and we've
only got about 30 seconds though are you
able to start i mean it's small article
i'm hoping you can sum it up
in a brief amount of time
so uh yes whether balloons boss tim
martian uh would like more generous
visas really to
get staff for pubs because so many
people have left the hospitality
sector not just since brexit he's an odd
and brexiteer which as i suppose some
people
might find somewhat ironic here but
obviously he says well we need we need
more staff anyway the pandemic has also
impacted us one in ten people roughly
has left the hospitality sector
but he would like them according to
british rules and not according to eu
ones so he's got a bit of a mix and
match menu
but there is a serious lack wherever you
stand in the brexit debate the
serious lack of staff in the hospitality
and bar sector
i think that was almost exactly 30
seconds you're very obedient and
efficient thank you very much indeed